LESTER CHEN: Thanks
so much, Emily.
So I will assure you all a
disclaimer that our slides
won't be as graph-heavy as
Andreas', and we won't be
talking about stage rollouts
and whatnot kind of like Emily,
but--
TIMOTHY EVANS: Over the head.
LESTER CHEN: Over the head.
But we're here talking
about content, and content
as it relates to YouTube.
And I'm on the YouTube end,
and who better to bring
than a YouTuber himself?
You're all the way from Boston.
And we're be talking about
mobile gaming content
and the rise of
how users have been
consuming content on YouTube
around this category.
So I'll do some slides.
Let's see about where
mobile gaming has come from.
So obviously a huge evolution
from linear puzzle games
like a Tetris to all of a
sudden, a worldwide interactive
[? PVP ?] game such
as Clash Royale.
And when talking about these
kind of games and the way
that content is
consumed, they obviously
have very different
characteristics.
Replayability,
iterative game modes,
which gives folks
like Tim a lot more
content to make
once a game is both
launched and has DLC
coming out regularly.
So mobile gaming on YouTube
has really seen a huge increase
in the past two
years, as far as hours
watched is a main metric
that we use at YouTube.
Not so much views anymore,
more just total empirical hours
or time watched has just
completely blown up.
And I think games like
the Supercell games,
Clash of Clans, Clash Royale,
games like Pokemon Go,
which saw a huge
spike last year,
and other games like Puzzles
and Dragons or Lineage or Angry
Birds have really led to this
sudden increase on both content
produced and content consumed.
So this is just a brief timeline
of how watch time on YouTube
has been really expanding
since all the way in 2015.
So as you can see, the
launch of Clash Royale
led to a little bit of a spike.
And then last year Pokemon
was a phenomenal event
that we've been tracking,
which led to a sudden peak.
The slope is still
very much steady,
and we see a steady
increase in the way people
are consuming games.
And it's really encouraging
to see creators also adopt
mobile-first
strategies in the way
that their channel
DNA is composed.
So, Ash, to you.
So I was kind of
doing some digging.
TIMOTHY EVANS: Uh-oh.
LESTER CHEN: And I think
September 2, almost three
years ago, was the first time
that you really took a stab
at uploading YouTube content.
Can you tell me a
little bit about what
was going through your head
when you were thinking,
what is the first video before
hitting the Publish button?
TIMOTHY EVANS: Sure, yes.
So I had absolutely
no experience
in a, mobile gaming, or
b, in YouTube, certainly.
So I lacked the
technical expertise along
with just the
networking that you
would think one
should have if they
want to endeavor to establish
a really good YouTube channel.
So I didn't have any of that,
and I had really bad quality
to boot.
And I just uploaded a
few videos just for my--
it was for Clash of
Clans at the time,
and it was just for my guild,
my clan inside the game just
to cover special events
that we were hosting.
And now three years later,
I'm here on the stage with you
somehow.
I don't know how the
heck it happened, but--
LESTER CHEN: So
obviously, like you said,
your content started off--
I'll be a dick here
and say it was rough.
TIMOTHY EVANS: Yeah,
to say the least.
LESTER CHEN: I was watching
it, and it was pretty bad.
[LAUGHTER]
And now--
TIMOTHY EVANS:
What a great host.
LESTER CHEN: Now, you have
a very beautiful intro.
And clearly, I
think directionally,
things have changed.
But can you tell me what
has necessarily changed,
both within the game?
What's giving you
more encouragement
to continue uploading?
TIMOTHY EVANS: Yeah, so I
think you were being kind.
It was absolutely awful.
You can see I didn't even
utilize the full landscape
mode.
But I think that when
I started, I just
wanted to do it purely
as a small little hobby.
I didn't even think it was
possible for someone like me.
When I started my YouTube
channel, I was 32.
I was playing with
16-year-olds-- kind of creepy,
I know.
But I didn't think that I had
that infectious personality
that could certainly
take off, so I just had--
I set really, really
minimal goals for myself,
just learning one
new thing a week
and trying to apply
it to my channel,
as I like to tackle
bigger things in life.
No matter what
you're doing is try
to continue to get better at it.
So that led to not even
close to where I see myself
right now as the final product.
So I'm still kind of
continuing on those trends,
but, yeah, just one
thing at a time.
LESTER CHEN: And
you're up to-- what--
like 500,000 subscribers?
TIMOTHY EVANS: We're closing in.
We're closing in, but yeah.
Yeah.
So certainly not the
biggest in the ecosystem,
but just to inject a
little bit of pride,
I've managed to do
it sticking to myself
and not being
someone who I'm not,
and covering more
strategic elements of games
rather than being
a big personality.
LESTER CHEN: So in your opinion,
there's obviously tons of--
it's very subjective.
Really, what makes good content,
and what did you find really?
Did you stick to--
and I guess is
this the game subject matter?
Was this a certain format?
What do you really define
as good content and content
that your audience
really not only watched
for the first time,
but continued watching?
TIMOTHY EVANS: Yeah,
so it's definitely
different for every individual,
and every content creator,
and every developer
what kind of content
you're looking for your game.
But for me, I've
always just strived
to make content that
I would want to watch.
Really basic and
cliche, but I just
think it takes a lot of grit
when you're starting out
in YouTube just as you're
starting out as a game
developer where you're
not going to experience--
as much as people like to
believe their channel's
going to blow up one
day and they're just
going to be a millionaire, it
just doesn't work like that.
You have to get through
that first year,
or even more sometimes, of
seeing stagnant, if any,
growth.
So what I think makes
good content is being
true to yourself,
and, at the same time,
not being afraid to be
transparent, and also
be honest.
So I've always built
my channel around--
even if I have
good relationships
with all the developers
that I work with,
I think that I'm honest.
And I really love opinion
pieces, if you will.
So I just think making your
content worth watching,
no matter what that
vehicle is to get it there,
is really important.
How do you differentiate
yourself from everybody
out there making content
on the same games?
So I think being a little bit
m but staying true to yourself,
working within your
personality, to make content.
LESTER CHEN:
Something I've noticed
is some of these
top grossing games
oftentimes don't have any
or very low viewership
on the YouTube platform.
Do you have any kind of
intuition or hypothesis
around that?
Games that a ton of people
play, and spend, and clearly
come back after the first
try, but they really
aren't watching any
kind of content.
What are some things you
really think lead to that
or some of the problems there?
TIMOTHY EVANS: Yeah, so the
developers that I work with
have really valued community
almost to its detriment
at some times, but it
pays off in the long term.
Some developers are
lucky enough to have
billions of marketing
dollars, if not hundreds
of millions or millions.
And those type of
games, in my opinion,
no matter what they
do, they're going
to succeed because they're
throwing so much money.
Like Mobile Strike--
no offense if Mobile
Strike's developer's here--
but if you throw
millions and millions
and millions of
dollars into the game,
of course you're going
to generate users,
thus rank high on
the app store, thus
continue to get that momentum.
But I think that what a
lot of developers miss
is how to use content
creators strategically
to grow that ecosystem
around their game.
And I think they do it in
the wrong way a lot of times.
I'm sure we'll talk
more about in a bit.
LESTER CHEN: Yeah, yeah.
Well, you talked briefly
on the detriment sometimes
of growing community.
I have to guess negative
feedback and kids
on Facebook saying, yeah.
TIMOTHY EVANS: Which can
be good though, yeah.
Yeah, so the games
I cover, I mean,
they can't put out a
tweet about their game
without getting the top
tweets, your game sucks.
It's dying, whatever.
But that's a good thing
because people are still
passionate about it.
It's better than sending
out a tweet about your game
and getting absolutely
no response.
LESTER CHEN: Right.
So I want to touch on the
nuances right of capturing
mobile content.
I come from the
PC console world,
so I think the path was
a little bit clearer when
certain hardware like
capture cards were released,
and encoding
software, and the way
to just to record both like
VOD content and live streams,
it was a lot more
commonly known.
But when it comes to mobile
content and how you capture it,
can you talk a little
bit about your set-up
and maybe some of the nuances
of how you can capture
from a device or from
your tablet or phone,
and how you actually
eventually get
the video content that you're
recording to your computer
and up on YouTube?
TIMOTHY EVANS: Sure.
I think this is a hurdle that's
becoming easier and easier
to clear with technology
moving in the direction
where you can easily
record your device.
However, I think it's really
paramount for developers
to work with content creators to
help increase their production
value.
And you can record right
from your screen now
with a lot of different apps,
a lot of mirror-type apps.
Me, personally, I use a
hardware called Delgado,
where you can just use a
lightning cable or HDMI cable
and just hook right up directly.
So there's a lot of ways to
do it, even with emulators.
But it's up to basically try
to find the highest quality
way that you can possibly
a, understand, and b,
afford to use.
LESTER CHEN: Well, I think it's
ironic because a lot of people
are consuming the mobile
game content on their phones.
But the broadcasters,
you're still
pretty much wired to a very
static kind of set-up, right?
TIMOTHY EVANS: Indeed, yeah.
LESTER CHEN: Until Wi-Fi
capabilities and some things
might be able to shift, or
storage space even on a phone,
you're still kind of locked
to a very static set-up.
TIMOTHY EVANS: Yeah.
Yeah, it's true.
And I think that
hopefully, we'll kind of
move in the right direction.
But yeah, that's kind of
where it is right now.
LESTER CHEN: So let's
talk about ways developers
have embraced YouTubers,
like going left to right.
Someone like the largest
YouTube creator PewDiePie
had worked with a developer
in order to make his own game.
I think Supercell does quite
a good job using their talent
as beacons to both announce game
mode launches, or new cards,
or anything else
going on, and then
Best Fiend's model, where
YouTubers and influencers are
actually built into the games.
In your experience,
what have you seen,
or what are your best
practices or ways
that developers have
used both you and some
of the community in the space?
And what is good,
and what is bad?
TIMOTHY EVANS: Yeah, so I
started out back in 2015
when I got into the
NDA club for Supercell.
And at that time, there
was only 11 people.
I was the 11th.
We're in a small
little Skype group
with not a lot of organization.
I mean, they did a
good job, obviously.
They were one of the first
major mobile developers
to embrace YouTubers.
But at that point, now in
just three short years,
we've grown to over 200
people, content creators,
and it's run in a lot
of different ways.
But with the big
companies that already
have that ecosystem of content
creators, it's really easy.
So we have those relationships.
They say, hey, a new
game's coming out,
and boom, we're there.
That's it.
But two pillars of
Supercell has always
been even before they blew up
with Hay Day and Clash of Clans
in 2014 and '15, they've
never paid anybody
to cover their games,
a, and they've never
given in-game resources, which
are two really strong values
to have.
And I think that it's
really easy to say that
and really hard to execute on a
community or a content creator
strategy without using
those two resources.
But they've always had
that mentality that we just
want people to
organically play our game
or cover our game without having
to give them stuff to do it.
So instead of
that, they've tried
to create ways to grow
influencers' channels who they
work with as the
carrot, and then they'll
want to cover the game because
they'll get so many views.
So I think that the
best ways to try
to build your own community
of content creators
if you're a developer,
in my opinion,
just from seeing so
many companies pay
so much money to my
colleagues and me, the offers
that we get for one video can
triple our monthly YouTube
income.
So I don't think that that's
money necessarily well spent,
although it might acquire
more users as advertising
on Facebook, say.
But I do think that's the
best strategy in my opinion--
and I've consulted with other
developers who've done this--
is to pick small to mid-tier
YouTubers who you're
a real big fan of
their production,
you feel like they
jive well with what
you're trying to
portray to the public,
and try to help them grow.
And the biggest
incentive for me,
especially when I was
a smaller YouTuber,
is to share their content
in game, especially
revolving around updates.
Because what that does
is it sends your traffic
from the game to the content
creator's YouTube channel,
and that incentivizes
us to continue
to cover the game beyond just
that one sponsored video.
So I think that moving a
step further than that,
having live events.
I've gone to travel the
world, been lucky enough.
And like I said, it's surreal
to me because I'm a 35-year-old.
I was a mail carrier
for 13 years,
and just not much
going on in terms of--
LESTER CHEN: Don't
discredit mail carriers.
TIMOTHY EVANS: You already
dissed my production quality.
I might as well just drive
myself into the ground.
But seriously, ultimately,
it's just the fact
that there's a big
thirst, I think,
for content creators
and community.
And I think that neither
the content creators,
nor the third parties who work
with the developers and content
creators, or the
developers really
utilize it in a great way.
LESTER CHEN: Would
you say, then,
that the community
at some point takes
on a little bit of
a life of its own
and transcends maybe
even the updates,
or keeps the valleys alive while
peek updates are in the works?
TIMOTHY EVANS: Absolutely,
yeah, for sure.
And I worked with a
smaller developer,
and we recruited
just two YouTubers,
one with 4,000 subscribers and
one with 9,000 subscribers.
And we put them into
their game, just like I
talked to you about earlier.
And now, they're organically
covering the game.
And that's the
best case scenario,
because then you
can grow together,
and then your players know
where to find information
about updates, about
whatever content
that you want to
highlight, and it's
a symbiotic relationship
rather than just
a transactional relationship.
LESTER CHEN: Sure.
So, yeah, we were joking
about this before.
Again, I--
TIMOTHY EVANS: Another
flattering pic.
LESTER CHEN: Could have picked
a better picture on this one.
But I think it's
really interesting
when talking about the
day in the life of someone
who does this as your career.
Like you said, you
were delivering
mail for almost over a decade,
and then you just recently
within the past six months--
TIMOTHY EVANS: Yeah, like
eight months or so, yeah.
LESTER CHEN: --eighth
months, transitioned
to doing content
creation full-time.
What does a day in the
life of you look like?
What is a good day,
and what's a bad day?
And how can developers, and how
can the game publishers help
with making your days better?
TIMOTHY EVANS: That's
a big question, Lester.
I think that my life
is certainly not
anything that exciting.
I go to an office.
I rent an office space, and I
just work on my video early,
and get that all set.
And then, of course,
leaving a government job,
albeit not the best
one in the world,
but just a steady government
job for something as insecure,
or at least it
feels so insecure,
as a YouTube channel
is a big step.
So what I've done
is basically put
as many eggs in different
baskets as I possibly could.
So I do consulting,
and I work for a couple
of startup companies.
Also, I'm a community manager
for a game coming out soon.
So I think that what
I've tried to do
is just provide that conduit
from the influencers,
the developers.
And I just spend most of my
time just networking, really.
So as far as what a developer
can do for somebody like me is
I just think that we need to
have a healthier relationship,
developers and content creators,
because I think that we
both have a lot to offer.
But for some reason, like
I said before, there's just
that missing link somewhere.
Right now, I don't think
the current system really
works for anybody.
LESTER CHEN: Be honest.
How long do you spend responding
to comments on your YouTube
channel?
TIMOTHY EVANS: An
hour, actually.
I spend an hour a
day, which is probably
59 minutes more than
anybody else does
because it takes a lot of time.
This is apropos of
nothing, I guess,
but I find that to get
good YouTube engagement,
if you train your
viewers that you're
going to respond in the first
half an hour, hour, hour
and a half, however
long that is,
it creates a real huge spike in
community around your channel.
So I think that that's
really key to my growth
strategy in YouTube.
LESTER CHEN: So we've touched
on this in many different ways.
But when I was looking
at the landscape of some
of these games that even the
past two years have exploded,
and I look at the volume
of games, and then
I also look at the volume
of YouTube channels
that have sprouted up--
I think I was pulling
some stats before this.
I think currently, there's
around 39 or 40 YouTube
channels this year that
breached the 1 million
subscriber mark, so huge
kind of new audience,
where mobile-first or mobile
gaming creators are also
attracting a mobile
viewing-first audience.
Is there like a prescriptive
recipe for success?
I think you maybe
touched on it when
talking about going for
the middle-tier channels.
But do you see any kind of
pattern that tends to work more
frequently than ones that don't?
TIMOTHY EVANS: Yeah.
Like you said, I touched
on like some of the things
that I feel passionately about.
I do feel like just
paying for videos is just
not a good strategy.
I mean, Pokemon Go,
Vainglory, Supercell Games,
a small minority of
companies who don't do that.
I'm sure there's
a lot of others.
But I just don't think
it's a great strategy.
I think that having live
events and developing community
like that, and maybe paying for
somebody to make an appearance
is OK.
And then there's other
ways to do things as well.
Like, if you reach out
to a content creator,
they might not even
know your game.
So how are you going to
get them to the point
where you want to show off
your game without giving them
at least in-game resources?
But some strategies that some
companies that I've worked with
have used is just giving
them stock footage,
and then allowing
them to maybe play
the game on an account
that's progressed
a little bit further, but not
giving them that as a resource.
Because I think valuing your
own game's in-game economy
to the fact that you just
won't give it out to people
that promote you is important.
But, of course, that's
probably an unpopular opinion
because it's what
everybody does right now.
That's what all my
emails are filled with.
So I do think that
the missing link here
is that you want people to
cover your game organically,
but they won't do that
unless they get the views.
So how do you--
LESTER CHEN: Reconcile that.
TIMOTHY EVANS: --remedy that?
LESTER CHEN: It's an
interesting kind of thing.
Because I noticed especially,
too, the amount of news
generated I think between
the large updates on games
is often like, what do you
do when there's not enough
content to be created around?
I think they touched
on it before.
It's like you want
to launch your game
with a lot of content.
But then when you also think
about the long-term cycle
of the game, what happens to you
as a creator when there isn't--
like, how long would
you say that threshold
is before you start
being like, man, I've
got to move on to a new
game, or there's not
enough content to be made here?
TIMOTHY EVANS: Yeah.
It's tough from our perspective
just as a developer perspective
is just that you can
only do a video daily.
I have almost 1,300 videos.
But you can only do videos
daily on the game doing
the same thing for so
long unless you really
have a unique set of
something that you're
bringing to the table.
So I have my own kind of
flavor, but you're right.
We're always looking
for that next game
that's going to take off.
And the problem is that
boxes out all the small games
that are worth looking into.
So I don't know the perfect
solution other than--
LESTER CHEN: It's
almost like flip-flopped
where you said maybe some of
the developers or publishers
should look at the
middle-tier creators.
TIMOTHY EVANS: I think so.
LESTER CHEN: It's
almost like you
might be able to find a niche
by looking at some of the--
TIMOTHY EVANS: I think so.
I think that if I was
going to develop a game
and I want to create a great
strategy for getting content
creators on board, I
would try to reach out
to someone who has a
little bit of influence
inside the ecosystem, and
then have them almost recruit
other content creators who
are smaller to bring on board.
That's my favorite strategy
of growing a community.
Or even taking
someone who's maybe
an influencer in
your game-- maybe you
don't have content creators
who cover your game,
but you have forums
of passionate players.
Maybe just mentoring and paying,
hey, we'll buy you whatever,
a PC if it takes it.
We'll buy you an Elgato
to a smaller scale,
and we'll share your
content, and we'll
help you grow together.
I think that's a
great strategy to use.
And it doesn't pay those
immediate dividends
like a paid promotion does--
and maybe there is a time and
a place for a paid promotion.
But I just don't think it's
a good community-building
strategy, just Instant
downloads, you know?
LESTER CHEN: So moving on,
I think a big question--
this is a loaded slide--
but what is in your eyes
the future of mobile gaming?
When I look at each
of these, I think
of a new super-massive game
IP that could horizon and have
huge implications in the West.
I think Supercell, obviously,
has Brawl Stars coming out.
That could be interesting as far
as the size of the company it's
coming from.
Again, there's an
e-sports aspect
to consider as far as
extending a mobile game's
IP with something like
the Crown Championship.
And then lastly, just talking
with devices and hardware.
Like, phones that have
better built-in both cameras,
and hardware, and
usability, and screen size,
and all these things.
And you can jump into
any one of these.
Where do you really see
some of these futures going?
TIMOTHY EVANS: Geez.
Like you said, it is
a big, big question.
But me personally, I think
that a lot of the global market
has been devalued based
on the advertising dollars
or of various other factors.
But I think that might be
a mistake, just from a--
I've never seen a more
passionate base of players
than I've seen in, say,
Brazil, the Portuguese,
Spanish-speaking
communities, or India.
I think that that's an untapped
audience, to some extent.
And even in countries
less fortunate,
everybody still has a mobile
device, or a lot of people do.
So I think that there's
millions of players who can be--
basically, there's
a big appetite
for these games
in those markets,
but people just
don't market to them
because that's not what
advertisers want, oftentimes.
So I think that the
future of mobile gaming
is definitely global.
And I think that capturing
that global market
should be a priority,
at least in my mind.
I can tell you that covering
Clash Royale and Supercell
games as I do, there's
no more rabid fan base,
there's no more faster
growing fan base
than those Spanish-speaking
and Portuguese-speaking
communities, even Germany
to a lesser extent,
and India, Malaysia,
Philippines.
These are all markets
that the appetite is
so huge for these mobile games.
So I think that
just capitalizing
on the global scale and
not devaluing it too much
just because of advertising.
And the bottom line, I think
that that could be a mistake.
I think that the
future is global.
These games all have
such huge potential.
Arena of Valor with
Strike of Kings
in China, which is the number
one game last two years,
incredible.
The government
instituted laws where
it's limiting the
amount of play that you
could have on a mobile
game, which is crazy.
So that's been rebranded
to Arena of Valor,
and it's launching in November.
CCGS, which is the Clash
Royale Global Championship,
proves that mobile
can be an e-sport.
And we'll see just how
far they can take that,
but it is a $1 million
contest in London next month.
So it's playing a mobile
game, which is something
we've never seen before.
LESTER CHEN: Yeah.
I know we were discussing
this at lunch, kind
of like a revenue-first
model between developers
having a lot of hooks in
order to incentivize purchase
and whatnot, and how that also
fits in the same conversation
of fair competitive
play, like making sure
that there's an equal
playing field, that it's
embracing the every man or
woman to play competitively.
Do you have any opinions
about that or how
you see the balance between
revenue-driving games
versus purely competitive games?
Because I think it's
hard to really breach
the gap of e-sports without
really addressing that.
TIMOTHY EVANS: Yeah.
People way smarter than
me have spent so much time
thinking about this.
And I think that, at least
from Supercell's vantage point,
again, who I work with closely,
and Tencent as well, it's
making sure that you value
the casual gamer as paramount
to your success, and
at the same time,
building that infrastructure
for competitive gaming
as an afterthought
at this point.
I wish it was more than that,
but that's just what I've seen.
And maybe Vainglory
being the one exception
right now in mobile
gaming, which they're
really full-throttle onto
the competitive scene,
not so much on the casual scene.
But then I think that
ultimately, there's
a reason they're not
quite as successful
as the other big games because
they've honed in so closely
on those.
LESTER CHEN: Sure.
So this is kind of
geared towards you
just because the
start of your channel
has been on Clash of Clans.
You've evolved in the past few
years towards Clash Royale.
And you can take it
a few different ways,
like, as far as community
building, not just
gameplay mechanics,
releases, or anything else
like that, who do you really
think as far as philosophy goes
can really step up to the plate?
TIMOTHY EVANS: Yeah.
So without naming any
certain developers,
I think that creating
that community
is definitely so, so important.
I think that like we've talked
about for this whole discussion
is to not at least try to
get content creators on board
with your game.
They'll patch up
some of those holes
that we talked about
between updates,
between major features that
are being added to the game.
They'll help you, and
they'll create a community
around your game.
And having people talk
about your game is awesome.
So I think that the
next company that can--
it's a multi-pronged,
I guess, answer,
but developing community,
working with content creators,
and making an awesome game.
I mean, obviously, the game
has to be good for people
to ultimately want to play it.
And I think everybody as a
content creator, everybody's
always on the lookout for who's
going to be the next Supercell,
or who's going to be the
next big developer to give us
viability because we're
looking for long-term viability
as a content creator just
as developers are, too.
So what is the life
of a game right now?
It's something that no one even
knows exactly the answer, what
is the life of a mobile game?
Clash of Clans has been
going strong for five years,
but is that an aberration,
or is that the norm?
It's difficult. And I know I've
really dodged the question,
but I don't know who's going
to be the next Supercell.
I think that, hopefully,
given platforms like YouTube,
given platforms like
Twitch, and stuff
like that, that developers
can somehow work better
with content creators
moving forward
to make multiple Supercells
instead of just one or two.
Who do you think's going to
be the next Supercell, Lester?
LESTER CHEN: That's
what I'm asking.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm like, don't
turn it back on me.
Yeah, well, I
appreciate that thought.
And I think from a content
creation standpoint,
it clearly relies
on replayability,
the ability to seed content so
that there's always freshness.
And I think it's a lot
about developing things
outside of just like the
standard out of the box
gameplay.
How can you evolve that?
What are some institutionalized
ways of thinking of game modes
that can be completely reversed?
I think different modes,
and using derivative IP,
and figuring out
different ways to play
with that, I've noticed, give
content creators a lot more
to bite on.
And also modes which lead
towards unreachable goals
or really hard goals.
TIMOTHY EVANS: Yes,
that's a good one.
That's a good one.
LESTER CHEN: Right?
I think that no one
thought that anyone
would get to X top leader board,
or X wins, or to some status.
And I think building in
mechanics which the person will
play every single day and
also record every single day,
because I think you want
to get an audience who's
inherited in your journey
of doing something.
And I think that with you
YouTube creators or even
streamers, having a goal is--
like you coming full circle,
that was like, what do you want
to do at the end of the series?
Are you doing a series
on competitive play?
Are you doing a series on tips?
Are you doing a series
on anything else?
What is the start?
And what's the finish?
I think for developers
I've personally
noticed that setting these
goals, like unreachable goals
also within games help for that.
TIMOTHY EVANS: Yeah,
I think that you
hit the nail on the head.
Coming from a bit of an
MMO PC background side,
I love the grind.
And even if people say
they don't love the grind,
I think that deep down, they do.
It makes the game
sticky, and it makes you
want to stay around to compete.
LESTER CHEN: Yeah.
Well, I think we're
out of time here.
I'm going to kick it
over to Dan Atkins.
He's over at the
Daydream team, so he'll
talk a little bit about building
VR experiences within apps
and games.
TIMOTHY EVANS: Cool.
Thanks, Lester.
LESTER CHEN: Thanks, Ash.
TIMOTHY EVANS: OK.
Thanks, man.
[APPLAUSE]